one of the police officers charged in
the killing of George Floyd is Thomas
Lane
Thomas Lane has hired a lawyer named
Earl Gray and I can tell you this guy is
not at all
lemony and mild like Earl Grey tea he's
actually quite the opposite and he
imploded on live television last night
he was interviewed by CNN's Chris Cuomo
and Earl Grey tried to suggest that if
bystanders were really so concerned with
how George Floyd was being manhandled by
police why didn't the bystanders jump in
to restrain the police he actually says
this and then he has no choice but to
back away from it when Chris Cuomo tells
him how bonkers it is what if all these
people say why why didn't my client
intercede well if the public is there
and they're so uh an uproar about this
they didn't intercede either in my
clients town where he can't really hold
on counselor counselor hold on hold on
yes sir things once you're laying on a
man's legs you've got a fine view of
what's going on with that man the other
officer is literally a foot in front of
you on his neck - I understand that he
has a senior officer telling him what to
do but there's also a duty to intervene
anythingit officer is doing something
that's dangerous to a civilian you have
a duty to intervene and he did not
intervene and the idea that the
civilians should have rushed in to a
policing situation in the inner city of
Minneapolis against four police officers
that have weapons and are kneeling on
the neck of a man don't you think that's
asking a little much of civilians and a
little too little of your client
absolutely I'm not I just brought that
up
well what you say is it went away well
he's got his feet he was holding his
feet down mr. king was officer King was
next and then shavon so obviously the
suggestion of civilians intervening
against armed police is ridiculous and
Earl Grey realized it and has to back
off and say well I'm merely
get up could this guy possibly be a good
lawyer his defense of his client Officer
Thomas Lane was to ask why didn't
civilians commit a crime because if
civilians actually go and try to
interfere with four armed officers in
the process of restraining and
subsequently killing George Floyd they
would have been arrested and likely
charged with interfering with law
enforcement now this is a good
opportunity to step back and give you a
sense of in general how the other
officers meaning the ones that were not
george derek shavon might approach their
defenses the idea is to say there was a
power dynamic these guys like Thomas
Lane who is represented by attorney air
Earl Grey they were following orders
they weren't really in a position
because of seniority differences to
disagree even if they wanted to now
here's our friend Josh Campbell Campbell
former FBI agent CNN reporter friend of
the David Pakman show
asking Earl Gray about is this the PAP
is the power dynamic thing what you were
going with and Earl Grey didn't like it
at all take a look were you kind of
applying a power dynamic between the
masher right but is he really is your
claim that he was following orders your
client so Earl Grey getting very upset
there with a pretty straightforward
question
from josh campbell and then again
another example this is Earl Grey
explaining my client couldn't really do
anything I mean he couldn't restrain
Derek shavon take a look be unreasonable
for my client to go up and try and drag
Charlaine off of
he's got a Tony year cup in the front
and my guys back there with four days
shall we roll him over and he says no
won't wait for the ambulance twice and
then he says he's suffering from a
delirium I don't know what what you're
supposed to do as a cop so that's the
gist of at least how Earl Grey will seek
to defend Thomas lanes actions in the
killing of George Floyd he was only on
the job a few days he didn't have the
power dynamics on his side he did
suggest rolling George Floyd over and he
couldn't really physically restrained
Eric Shaw in any way which is probably
accurate he physically restraining Derek
shavon was not a likely path so we've
talked about many reforms by the way but
one that might benefit police is to
reorganize some of these a sort of
standards of the chain of seniority
there's a really interesting story that
Malcolm Gladwell tells in his book
outliers nearly 12 years ago at this
point about South Korean pilots which
explained that South Korean culture
precluded co-pilots from pointing out to
captain's
hey I'm seeing something that doesn't
look right and under that cultural norm
South Korean aviation was not
particularly safe and so South Korean
Airlines retrained and said listen the
in the cockpit we have a different
protocol than in Korean culture and
first officers not only should be
allowed to but they should be encouraged
to point irregularities out to captain's
you won't be punished it's the right
thing to do and when they reorganize
that norm cultural norm in this case
South Korean aviation became
dramatically safer and much the same way
it is probably true that an officer on
duty for four days this is not a defense
of Thomas Lane but that one element is
true in police culture in the ranks it
would be seen as inappropriate or
unacceptable to question the tactics
of the senior officer in that particular
case that needs to be changed and that
is totally separate from how any of
these individual charges are ultimately
going to play out let's take a quick
break my interview with Neil Ferguson is
next make sure you're following the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show this episode is sponsored by
blue chew one of the things I make a
priority on the show is not to
perpetuate stigma for things that don't
deserve it we've talked about mental
health we've talked about many things
where we should all just be respectful
adults period and we would be better off
and blue two can increase performance
and give you that extra confidence you
may be looking for blue to calm blue
like the color blue is the first
chewable with the same fda-approved
ingredient as in Viagra and Cialis it
can be taken day or night even on a full
stomach since it's chewable it works
twice as fast as a pill whenever the
opportunity arises blue chew is
prescribed online by licensed doctors
you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you don't have to wait in line at
a pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discrete package they're made in
the USA and since blue troop repairs and
ships direct it's cheaper than a
pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue to
calm get your first shipment free when
you use our promo code Pakman that's PA
que ma n Pages $5 shipping that's blue2
dot-com promo code Pakman to try it
totally free blue chew is the better
cheaper faster choice and we thank them
for sponsoring the David Pakman show